here at the Scouting Combine in
Indianapolis a man who was entering his
second year as the head coach of the
Denver Broncos we saw you last year
coach and you came back you didn't learn
your lesson after talking to his last
year he's Vic Fangio coach of the
Broncos congratulations on your first
year a lot of good right and I'm sure
some areas of improvement as you go into
year two but all in all I think the
Broncos are moving in the right
direction
I hope so you know we've ended the
season on a good note winning for the
last five we had some tough losses
earlier in the season and the guys we're
resilient kept moving forward and cave
to the disappointment of some of the
losses that we had and thought we ended
the season on a strong point and I think
the guys are in the right frame of mind
moving forward toughest lost overcome
had to have been the one in Minnesota up
20 points at halftime what was the key
to getting the guys to put that behind
them just to show you know the facts you
know where we failed why we lost the
lead and both sides of the ball and just
move on from there and where we could
learn but we had you know the one in
Indianapolis was right there the one
against Chicago was even worse so I mean
we had our we were experts there for a
while and not closing the games that we
were in position to win and then we did
that in the second half of the season
more than we didn't I think the best
news when you look at the whole season
was drool off we didn't see much of him
but I think he's got it
right there he's got that quality he's
got that intangible mean he can make the
throws but he's got that leadership he's
got that spark give me your assessment
even though it was a limited sample size
of Drew Locke as a rookie quarterback
well I was really glad to get him five
games you know cuz albeit it is limited
it's better than one or two or none and
he was all in right from the get-go I
think the biggest thing that and I think
drew getting hurt really helped him and
helped his career because he you know he
hurt this thumb on this throwing hand
which is a serious injury for a
quarterback and he missed three months
of practice
somehow someway from the middle of
August to the middle of November he
improved tremendously as an NFL football
player and a quarterback he engaged
himself in observations and in the
meetings watched Joe Flacco get ready
without the pressure of him having to go
out and perform and the guy came back a
much much better player without all that
practice through his observations and
one thing that I I noticed about him and
I remember listening to John Madden
callgames coach Madden always seemed to
gravitate toward the guys who were just
having fun
smiling enjoying themselves not freaked
out by the moment and that's my
perception of Drew Locke he was having a
good time the moments not too big for
him he knows he belongs and everything
just flows from that I think it's true I
mean we the one game we did lose in his
five was against Kansas City in Kansas
City and we really struggled that day we
lost 23 to three and you know we were
struggling to make a first down let
alone make score some touchdowns and it
never fazed him in a negative way he
kept going out there with confidence
that hey we can still go down and score
this series and to me that I learned
more about him that day than I probably
did the other games we had von Miller
Super Bowl week and we talked to him
about Patrick mahomes and and he told us
one of the things mahomes does when he
gets the ball he just drops back and
back and back and back and makes it just
harder to get to him e you've had a
chance to see him 1 full game and part
of another because he was injured in the
Thursday night game that he played in
Denver what have you picked up from
having a chance to study him directly to
watch him on film what and I know you
don't want to disclose a lot of your
secrets about how you plan to defend him
but is there anything you can pick up
from seeing what he does to try to
harness him corral him and limit him I
think limits the more
right word to use then to corral or
harness he started to do that too
he's a very talented guy he's the one
thing I think people miss when they talk
about him is because he's so talented
everybody is taken back by that this guy
sees the field very well and makes great
decisions you know some people like to
look at him as a gunslinger quarterback
the gunslingers throw interceptions he
doesn't so I mean we got a rare guy on
our hands here that the NFL is fortunate
to have we're unfortunate to be in his
division but been there before we you
know when I first came in Little League
Montana was in our division followed by
young and we all dealt with Aaron
Rodgers for a long time and this guy is
the has taken that all those Mantle's
over and it sounds like the challenge
for a team like that is you just got out
score them and you're developing the
offensive talent you've got the
receivers you've got the quarterback you
got the tight end and no offense you've
got Phillip Lindsey you've got the
potency offensively and I know a
defensive guy may not relish that but if
you're going to play the Chiefs your
best chance to beat them may be to put
more points on the board then you know
they're going to well you're gonna have
to to some degree I mean you want to
slow him down somewhat but that's a
chore in and of itself but they've lost
nine games in the last two years and one
of them was the winning team scored 29
the other seven they're between 31 and
54 so I think that paints a pretty good
picture to what you're alluding to
you're gonna have to score some points
what do you coach your defensive players
to do when a quarterback runs because
you know I've noticed like in the
Tennessee Kansas City AFC championship
game and I've seen it throughout the
year I saw it in the XFL over the
weekend Phillip Walker got toward the
sidelines PJ Walker now and slowed down
like he was going out of bounds and then
pulled the okey-doke and ran for another
12 yards what do you tell your guys to
do when the quarterbacks running the
football
well we take a good look each and every
week what the plate quarterbacks do in
those situations are they quick to slide
are they quick to go out of bounce or
are they somebody that's gonna compete
and try and get some extra yards so we
try and prepare them prepare them for
that knowing that it's not guaranteed
one way or the other so and the
defensive players are put in a tough
spot in those situations because the
minute they let up if the guy doesn't go
down take a slide or go out of Bounce
and they can look pretty bad so what we
try and study that what's the best
defense that you believe you've ever
coached all these years in the league
what's the one that you think back on
and say that was my best performance
those three years we had in San
Francisco were we had really good
players guys that were enjoyed playing
with each other and joy being coached by
us those three years were really good
our last season in Chicago we were
really really good you know we kind of
did everything you know we took the ball
away we stopped the run we rushed the
pad you know we had a great team now
that was only for one season we were
building up to that you know did a nice
job building a defense there and then we
added Kaleo McEnroe Klein Smith and that
put us over the top I mean going back to
my early years as a coordinator we had
good defenses in Carolina's expansion
team in the second year with Kevin Green
Sam Mills who Sam Mills should be in the
Hall of Fame made it to the final 15
this past year Lamar Lathan Eric Davis
you know we were good and we we got beat
by Brett Favre's Green Bay Packers the
year they won their Super Bowl we lost
them in the championship game and going
back to my earlier years as an assistant
you know obviously with the New Orleans
Saints when we had those linebackers you
know we were pretty good on defense then
too so when you've coached this long
you've been around a lot of great
players or you went in the coach this
long so they carry you real quick before
I let you go Vic Fangio give yourself a
grade
for Vic Fangio first year as head coach
of the Broncos seven and nine that's
what our record was so you know that's
really all that matters I'm comfortable
with the job we did as a coaching staff
we obviously can make some improvements
but I think I think we did find and but
ultimately it's seven and nine so
whatever that percentage is quickly do
the math that's what great I'll give
myself well we wish you the best going
forward thanks again for some of your
time I love what you have going on I
know it's not going to be easy in that
division but that makes it more
rewarding when the winds come coach
we'll have more from the Scouting
Combine here in Indianapolis after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports